repeat the first chapter of your book
transitions a director's journey and
motivational handbook starts with how to
quit
so what is this and why is that
important to start the book so you know
the one of the things that I wanted to
keep in mind with the book was that
I don't want to be prescriptive in in
saying this is the way you have to do it
and I also didn't want to be
um
overwhelming to the reader in the sense
of like you got to figure out you've got
to know what you want to do every you
know nook and cranny of your career
needs needs to be decided and then just
attack it because I know that it can
take people various amounts of time to
figure out what their what their voice
might be what their sensibility might be
what their appetite for whatever
different position you might seek in the
industry requires of you and so I wanted
to in the beginning
um
speak about curiosity and how much of uh
of a benefit or plus it is to have that
because if you're not curious I think
you start to become a little too
cemented in what you think works and
does not work and it's constantly
evolving
um and in route to figuring out what you
want to do specifically you're gonna
have to quit and so I wanted to
hopefully present that to the reader in
a way that it's not a derogatory word to
quit
um in fact when you choose to quit it's
an empowering thing so if you are
walking down a road of let's say you're
you're editing and you're like uh
editing's not for me
um and you pivot from editing to writing
or editing to producing that that
quitting can be a positive thing so it's
kind of my opportunity to Rebrand uh the
energy around the word quitting
and as they're quitting with finesse and
quitting with burning your Bridges
that's a great question I think that
um you can definitely quit with finesse
um uh
I think when it's clear what your goals
are then you know I think I maybe found
the right word or another word for it
which is a pivot I think I think
quitting can be just the pivot but I
also think you can burn you can end up
Burning Bridges if you do it if you
don't Dismount gracefully you know what
I mean so I think um
the idea is to not burn any Bridges
because you never know
when you're going to run into people
again and I think a lot of what we do in
the industry is built upon relationships
so
um burning them down is probably not
going to be in your favor but sometimes
that can be hard not to right because
I'm thinking if if let's suppose there's
personality differences but it's better
to as I like how you say a Dismount
gracefully
um that might be difficult and
especially if there's an ego at the top
and so
egos at the top tend to know each other
and could make phone calls so yeah just
how you
Dismount and making sure no one's pride
is hurt that's a difficult thing in any
industry I would imagine yeah it is I
feel like you know another thing that
I've I've come to try and add to my
process is like
certain relationships are going to be
and by I'm speaking more specifically to
like
um positions on a crew are going to be
contentious by virtue of the fact of
what each position is empowered to do
right so like an easy example is like a
cinematographer once more you know
equipment to beautifully capture the
show and a producer is
wanting to get the best look for the
least amount of money and so if we if
these two parties know that then they
can already accept that it's going to be
a lot of no's and a lot of y's and a lot
of you know uh seemingly contentious
exchanges it but if you know it's going
to be like that you can get past that
and kind of just have the conversation
you need to or maybe find a way to
embrace it with humor because we're all
just doing what we I hopefully you know
we're all just doing what the job
requires of us like if I if I want
another take at a scene
hopefully the actors know that I'm not
doing it you know for
um any reason other than I'm trying to
get the best
out of this moment you know but then on
the flip if an actor feels like they
don't have another take to give and then
they think that we've got it and you
know it seems like
they're really not willing to do another
one you know what I have to make a
decision on my end too and so it's
always it's kind of frequent navigation
of the interpersonal dynamics that you
have to find finesse in
and I think maybe as people get older
they realize okay I need to do the two
weeks notice or even a month or you know
have the talk and let them know you know
I'm I'm going to be leaving but I think
when we're younger and I'm speaking from
my own experience there are times when
you just go okay cool it's lunch time I
won't be coming back and and you think
that okay I'm 21 it's not going to
matter right but maybe just you know
don't take that interning job it's not
something I probably could have taken at
that age but if you can't
stay with it you know and and you know a
lot of times the the jobs we come across
that we don't enjoy oftentimes like
they're periods of time right like like
it might be a three-month commitment or
it's the duration of this film you know
sometimes it's can you get through it is
there anything else you can learn
outside of you know the thing that you'd
rather not be dealing with
um you know can you learn the inner
workings of how a film is produced while
being in that office that has a few
people that aren't your type of people
you know what I mean like can you can
you find the the value to take away from
it
um a lot of times it's
reconfiguring your perspective to get
something
guaranteed to propel you forward
did anyone question you about that
or did people praise you like well
that's great that's a great way to start
a book about it yeah I think people I
think there's a sense of relief and I
hope there's a sense of relief you know
for people who read it and they're like
okay yeah that's uh
I can I don't I'm not about to read a
book that's going to tell me you know
here's what you need to do and it's
going to help me find uh help me develop
some tools uh through which to
employ as I move toward finding my path
so the response has been great
I think it sets the tone that it's going
to be more reality based rather than
um you know just I don't know all these
cliches that you hear for years but that
you know that okay stuff is temporary
and you know it may not always be a fit
and that's okay and you may not be able
to fix it right right so
do you think that there's a time limit
on how long to stay with the job now I
realize it's different because TV
directing and that's short-term projects
usually but
yeah that's a great question I mean
I guess
so is there a time limit for how long to
stay with a job you know I feel like a
lot of what
happens in I'm gonna take film and TV
and try and marry you know those the
types of jobs that people have a lot of
times they're
they're they're
freelance driven or they're kind of
periodic so they kind of have their own
time limits where you know if you're on
a if you're editing a film you know it's
I don't know why I keep using editing
but if you're editing a film it's 12 to
18 weeks of your life you know and then
you can move to the next one
um TV show you know nine months maybe
fewer uh if you're a producer you know
that project is gonna project may never
go you know or it may it may be a small
window in time and then maybe you didn't
have a good time on it but they make a
sequel and you back out of it you know
because you want to have whatever peace
of mind you're looking for so I feel
like we have a unique
opportunity in this creative space to
not be married to anything too long
um so you can find a way to withdraw or
not continue without having to quit
um
but you know if and when that thing that
situation arises uh it's it's really
measuring what's the what's the real
benefit I mean I will say if there's
questions of of like mental health if
there's questions of like you know it's
just
an improper situation then by all means
like talk to the proper people and and
withdraw yourself from anything that's
you know not good for you
um but you know I think finding
being too ideal about how the work
experience should be can also leave one
you know missing out from the benefits
that they could take from a particular
job because I can tell you like if I go
through the jobs that I've had over you
know my career
and not many of them were awesome but
you know what I mean but a lot but I but
they're like I can always go back and
say oh I learned that thing from that
job and then who knew that four years
later I'd be able to take that thing and
and turn it into something that powered
what I was doing one of my first jobs
out of college was
um you know working for a company that
would kind of soon be over taken by IMDb
um but this was a company that you had
to pay for the information that is
available for free now
um and I had to call you know I'd read
the trades Hollywood Reporter variety
um I look at the film markets me fed
American Film Market whatever it was and
I would then call and say oh it says
that you uh
bought the rights to This Book Is it
true are you making this movie what
status is it in when might you begin
shooting it whatever and I hated that
job you know because I probably made 50
to 100 phone calls a day
but when it came time five years later
to raise money for my film my feature I
built a muscle up of like I can talk to
anybody you know because it's just a
conversation
um until they tell me no I don't want to
invest in your project
I have no problem following up because
that's you know just kind of this thing
that it was the byproduct of what I had
done begrudgingly for two years
that's fascinating was that the book
that was in Blockbuster
you know I well it was it was called
Baseline uh Studio systems and I don't
know I think it was all
they I mean I imagine they probably had
some physical
resource that you got
um but I believe it existed online and
then you just subscribe to it and got
whatever you got but that's how that I
mean I dealt with one little process of
it I don't even know what people got on
the other end of their of their payment
right oh that's fascinating so then
you'd had people hang up and and you'd
already sort of been you know that the
hazing of any telemarketer you probably
already yeah okay that's gonna happen
you know fine you know uh oh you don't
you know because there and then they're
on the flip there will be people would
be like I'm calling for my 900th attempt
to update this record because after X
amount of time we're gonna
check to see like should we make this a
a like a dead record or is it active you
know and so you're calling people and
it's like the production company
somewhere in North Carolina and it's the
same guy you've called eight times and
it's like hey how you been and they're
telling you a little bit more about the
trials and tribulations of of making the
film and you know you're building these
relationships in a you know in a weird
way
that's fascinating wow and so that that
must have really helped I'm sure yeah
then you then you're not scared yeah
yeah and just wrapping up so it sounds
like with most jobs if I were an HR
Manager and I looked at a resume with
all these different projects I'd be like
oh wow you've you've jumped around a bit
but in the film industry it sounds like
that's a plus yeah I mean I I you know
I would I imagine so I've been very kind
of tunnel driven with with my career
Pursuits but I do know like friends that
I've had in advertising like in the
commercial world it was shared with me
that it almost looked bad if you stayed
somewhere longer than two to three years
because then I guess what they were
saying is that it looks like you're
stagnant or it looks like
um you know you're not seeking to try
new ideas and and communicate in a
different way or you're not well sought
after you know so there's all these
little each industry kind of has its own
um take on
the activity of a of a resume
Pete I understand the first movie that
you wrote and directed got into Sundance
yeah so I mean I guess it's the first
one
that I put out to film festivals um the
short film I did called 3D it was my
senior thesis film coming out of NYU
film school so it's kind of like you
know if you were an undergraduate film
and you were like crazy enough to say
I'm a director like this was uh the path
and so
um did a 24 minute short film that I
wrote produced directed
had to raise twenty four thousand
dollars to make this film
um it was a different time because we
had to shoot on film so everything was I
it I mean people who have never sat on
film have no have no
um budgetary appreciation for what that
meant and the example I often use is
that uh we had to do an answer print so
um you know like when you used to
develop film
uh photographs you'd develop and then
you get the negative back uh in the
little pouch with the photos right
and you could continue to develop those
that negative again and again if you
needed to and so that's how we were
making films we had the negative
um but we had a work print and so we
would cut the work print but save the
negative and then when the work print
was finished we'd cut well not us
there'd be a negative cutter with white
gloves and glue who would cut the actual
negative that ran through the camera and
then cemented back together
to match the
locked picture from the work print and
then that cemented negative that it run
through the camera all the film that I
run through the camera now cemented
together in the you know configuration
of the film that's from that's the print
from which the
that's the
film from Winston prints get made and so
anyhow that cost four thousand dollars
for the negative cut
and now you could I've made shorts for
that amount of money you know and so um
anyhow that uh that film starred Dorian
Mystic who uh was an actor I met during
my NYU days and it's going on to being
four or five of my projects I started
Carrie Washington right at the beginning
of her career fresh out of George
Washington she was graduating the same
year I did
um Al Thompson myself
and it went to Sundance in about 30
festivals around the world
and so did
actually think that you could get into
something I mean were you thinking this
well just it's a wild card I mean that's
the thing I think over time what
it's nice to know
for me it was nice to know that there
were these potential
outlets for a project but I never did
the projects for those Outlets
so it was always enough for me to finish
something
that was kind of the point
um now that's not
removing the reality that I am aware
that these Outlets exist but it's like
this kind of filmmaker Zen Balancing Act
of like if I put all my weight on
acknowledgment from some outside group
then if I don't get that well what is
that going to do for me emotionally on
this end you know well I feel like I
failed well I feel frustrated will I
become embittered you know so
I didn't expect it I knew it could
happen and when it did happen I felt
like I had achieved something that was
pretty difficult
um
and so I was very happy about that but
that's kind of been that's been the
Journey of the whole career like how do
you navigate
um what you want
from what's
achievable and what can you guarantee
about this work that you do so you don't
you know find yourself
becoming one of those people who are
just
angry at how the industry has not
recognized them for what they think is
great work
what was the submission fee at that time
um you know what I have a pretty good
memory it was probably like 45 and it's
probably like you know 45 I didn't have
you know but uh that was I mean that was
always part of your budgeting too like
how much are we going to put aside for
film festival submissions um but it was
either it was either 35 or 45 dollars
I'm pretty sure
and so no Kickstarter no seed and Spark
no Indiegogo at that time no no and how
did you raise that you said 24 000 44
000. so I I raised the portion from
someone I had interned with
um I raised the portion from my mom a
small portion I raised a portion from
just knocking on doors and you know hey
remember remember you put those braces
on me you know uh well you look like you
might have a little bit of you know
money so uh it was kind of by hooker
crook you know I worked
um and you know it took it took a long
time
um to put it all together the film kind
of sat around for a while until
post-production money could be
raised
did you go to Sundance with the film I
did yeah yeah I did okay so when you
packed up to leave Sundance what was
your mindset thinking like okay now
things are really going to change for me
right yeah I mean I think I you know
that that's the thing right you kind of
get into this place where you you like
almost everything I've said to you I
could I could then you know shake the
Etch A Sketch and erase it all because
you try and temper yourself with this
you know healthy
um
view of expectations and then you get
into the thing and you're like okay
maybe this is it now
um and so yeah I think at that time I
was definitely
um
hopeful and expectant of certain things
to come out of it because I had watched
other people have a have a particular
kind of Journey after going to Sundance
and then you got back home and so you're
in New York City or in New Jersey okay
yeah
um so get back home I get a phone call
from uh Lynn Auerbach who
worked at the Sundance Institute she was
interested in seeing if I had a feature
or anything you know like what was my
next project luckily I did and so I
passed that feature script on to her I
had been very strategic because I'm I
often
I I try and tamper creativity with being
very deliberate and so I watched a lot
of filmmaking friends before me go to
Sundance get a similar call and not have
the next project and you know they say
oh we'll reach out when you know you
finish that script but like if you take
eight months to reach out well the
likelihood that they've reached out to a
new batch of people who had a you know
great film at another Film Festival is
high and I think you just want to when
that doorbell rings you want to answer
the door as far as I'm concerned and so
um I got her that script it wasn't
really you know ready or perfect in any
way but
it had fade in and Fade Out and About
113 pages in between and so um she read
it
um she was like well I don't think we're
gonna I don't think this is gonna be the
one but get me another draft and that
was all I needed so
um we did that dance for maybe a year
and a half
um before
they were like well look we're not going
to
select the film but we'll introduce you
to a bunch of producers in LA and set
you up with meetings and so that was
kind of the evolution of that what did
that experience teach you
so the experience of
going to Sundance and then coming home
and then the phone not ringing like uh
off the hook
um well in the book I talk about uh
after that
screening at nyu's Film Festival
um and and again taking a lot of that
expectation of certain acknowledgment
that I had at Sundance and bringing it
back home to to the university
we had a film festival that was uh
designed to screen all the work of all
the students that finished the project
and so um they would have a craft award
and they would have uh like a Wasserman
finalist so top three undergrad films
top three grad films and um
the film didn't get recognized in any
way whatsoever in any of the categories
and I and it had been advertised though
as you know a film to see or look at how
how well our slate of films is doing you
know here are these six films from this
year that went to Sundance including you
know 3D etc etc and so um
after the awards kind of came and went I
had a meeting with the dean at the time
or the chair rather and I was like look
how does this happen you know it's kind
of crazy to me this is this is righteous
indignant in me uh at what 22 years old
you know it's kind of crazy to me that
uh you're using the film to promote the
festival and how well you know the work
is in the festival but then with these
Awards it's like crickets or whatever
and he explained to me that well in the
past we've had a film when Sundance then
come back and not be acknowledged in the
way we're talking about so I was like
all right touche I didn't win you know I
get it
um and my takeaway from all of that was
I can either be upset about this which
it's clearly becoming
um evident that I'd be standing on very
unfirm ground with this anger
um what I'm taking away from this is
that I've never made I never took the
opportunity to build a network of people
who were aware of me you know as
um you know a student to watch or
someone that they had a have had a more
personal relationship with and so coming
out of that both uh Sundance and NYU
Film Festival I was pretty committed to
never having that happen again and so
building a community of folks who would
be aware of me and know my story and be
clear on where I wanted to go with my
career
um and that's how I you know Built My
production company rinse repeat I think
that's how I got into television
directing which was not just like a you
know so
I decided to do it and and it happened
it was very
um
deliberate and took a lot of time and a
lot of relationship building and so much
like the phone call job you know there
was this great takeaway from from those
two Film Festival experiences that I
think I'm not where I am today had I not
gone through them
and so did you actually go on meetings
did you fly out to LA oh yeah during the
time you did I went out to I went out to
NYU I went out to LA in June of o2
um and I had I don't know maybe 15
meetings set and uh you know
I stumbled my way through these meetings
I did the best I could I don't I looking
back I probably was full of passion but
maybe not didn't know how to run a good
meeting I present myself in like meeting
form and uh you know the takeaway from
the trip was well it looks like the film
is maybe a little too mainstream for
what the Sundance Institute was looking
to do and then on the flip it looks like
it's a little too Indie for what these
more mainstream producers at the time in
2002 are looking to do and let's just
pause and say it's a
vastly different landscape for content
in O2 it's like you had you had movies
made at Studios or mini majors
and then you have like
two or three Indies that fought through
and made it out it was a it was not this
kind of world where you see all these
Independent films and you could put them
out on whatever platform you want or you
could make them for cheap enough that
you know you could self-distribute them
through your website or something and so
um
yeah I brought that back and said well
I'm gonna if it's not gonna work for
either of these two demographics or
buckets or whatever we want to call then
looks like I'm gonna have to raise some
money on my own and that was
um that was my that became that be that
became my focus after that trip
and so not Indy enough for Sundance how
does that happen What
well I think I think it all I think it
changes with the times you know like I
think every Festival slate if you look
at any Festival year to year there's
kind of a theme that happens just that
kind of reflects the times and I think
in 2000 two
um
you know
the the the premise and the execution of
the film was not
necessarily like
leaning toward the types of
character exploration that might have
been more of the of the day as far as
like this is what an indie film is going
to do and all and all of these things
are like shifting terms you know so
that's another thing for like filmmakers
to
to always remember like these things can
shift they and blow in the wind they
change with with the times I mean I've
done TV shows where one year they say we
will never hire a first-time director
um you know when I was in route when I
was trying to get my first jobs and then
two seasons later
people I know are getting their first
ever episode of TV on the same show
and you know things things are free to
change but it's like just knowing like
it's also malleable it's also
um
you know nothing is set in stone
so do you think that if you had been the
same age then now and gotten into
Sundance that it would be more difficult
because you talked about building a
network well there was no social media
back then yeah no no Myspace even yeah
so yeah it was nothing right email was
your social network right AOL yeah
you've got mail right right so do you
think it'd be more difficult or do you
think it was actually easier then
because there were less people trying to
do it that's a great question
um so I think it was easier then
you know I would say it was
not easier than
while there may have been
it may have been more difficult to
it definitely was more difficult to make
something
and now that means there are probably
fewer things being made
but conversely I think because the
barriers to entry are lower now and it's
kind of been there's been a
democratization to like getting in the
game
um
you've got fewer things
being made in the past with poor
execution
and then you've got more things being
made now
but with people who have the opportunity
to execute well because it's not like
their first thing ever you know what I
mean and I remember when I when I saw
like friends Brothers
um like from my year of high school like
one friend's brother I'm thinking
specifically was like in middle school
and was doing like green screen stuff
you know what I mean it's like I hadn't
even done it yet I was like 24 I'd never
green screened anything yet and this
kid's in Middle School green screen and
stuff so you you take that and you just
move along the timeline of like now that
person's 22 with a short film that the
like the possibility for that short film
to be so much more well executed than
what I was making I think is
hi
how many years was it between
between showing at Sundance and getting
your first television directing job
so I went to Sundance in January of
2001.
I booked my first episode of television
in April of
17.
oh wow okay
so that would be 16
and a quarter years
but you were active
in film and television you worked at NYU
for a while
yeah I mean that whole time so to anyone
everyone watching and listening I never
stopped being a filmmaker and I think
you know that's part of what I try and
touch on in the book like you're you
have to Define yourself you have to
claim what you what you are and who you
are and so while I I work the desk job
at NYU I was assistant production
coordinator I was signing forms for the
students to go get film and you know
rent equipment or here's a voucher to go
to Kodak or whatever I was this I was
the signature toward other younger folks
dreams you know I answered a million
questions at the window because they
would come to our window and and get
this information and I would you know
give uh
unsolicited advice or it became sought
after people would kind of know that I
had
a real world skill that I could kind of
impart and offer to them
um I was you know I had my production
company during this time I had a podcast
um you know I was making things I won a
competition at Tribeca for heist
screenplay that I co-wrote in 2008
I wrote a bunch of screenplays I thought
I might sell that I never did and so
all of that time I was still
creating trying to I had a I had a I had
a Target on feature filmmaking because
that was what I had gotten into this
game to do you know
um and over time
you know this landscape was changing it
was the the types of films that I was
kind of interested in making were
becoming
uh obsolete because everything was
coming from some other intellectual
property like a comic book or an
amusement park ride like Pirates of the
Caribbean you know and like 20 million
dollar films 10 million dollar films
were kind of Disappearing and what I was
noticing was a lot of the people that I
wanted that I was inspired by that made
those films were moving the TV
because that's where there was more uh
there was a a a higher need there they
needed more they needed more content
um and the filmmakers that were kind of
sent to the Wayside by the new mandate
and features were going over to TV and
saying well
I'd love to tell that kind of story and
obviously all ushered in by Sopranos in
the Golden Age and watching these
interesting characters find exploration
episode after episode season after
season and so
um for yeah I think from like 09 until
2017 I had a pretty
pretty dedicated focus on trying to get
into TV
um but it took some time before I was
able to kind of
put it all together
did you ever feel this sort of common
thing that someone took your chance you
know I see it in our comments and and I
can understand why people get angry but
did you ever feel that at times no I
just felt I never thought I never felt
like someone took my chance I've I was
constantly trying to find the cocktail
that would work for me to
[Music]
get the opportunity and you know what
was clear and I'm a person who went
through four director programs that
um the studios and the networks were
compelled to put together
because the hiring was so
um clearly
angled in One Direction
um you know
I just felt like well how do I get
access to the people you know who were
making these decisions I felt like that
would be the big that I knew that that
was the biggest hurdle and so that that
hurdle was either making something that
people could see and doing that as often
as possible
um to give myself as many shots as
possible and then also discovering these
programs where you would get to learn
how television was made and be included
in these cohorts in these units that
were selected
to help bridge the gap between you know
93 of the directors being hired being
white males and seven percent
Encompass everyone else and so those
pipelines were helpful in kind of
meeting the folks learning how TV was
made and then
um
you know hopefully
shining enough to to get the
opportunities
anybody sit you down and say
Pete I know you mean well but like why
don't you have you thought about going
to law school
no right guy no nobody ever sat me down
or tried to send me in another Direction
I you know I feel like
I was I never had
I always had
people share maybe not the the the the
the
strength of belief in me but I feel like
everybody in my world
believed in me because
it was clear that I was being very
thoughtful about it it wasn't like
you know I didn't have like
delusions of grandeur of like what it
was going to take from me to get in the
industry
um I was informed on how it worked
um
when I met
a roadblock I tried to
hop up to 10 000 feet and look at it and
then say well what can I learn from this
and how can I pivot you know which is
kind of the whole like through line of
the book you know it's like there's
these you're gonna you're gonna have
your everybody's gonna have their own
journey and their own story but like
you're gonna find
opportunities and these challenges and
and you have to challenge yourself to
respond with your goal in mind and not
with your emotion and not with your you
know you know anything else
is this your quote right here Pete uh
yeah I said it may I I'll take ownership
right now maybe someone else has said it
somewhere in the world but yeah if you
ride the wave long enough the tide
always turns and what does that mean to
me that just is
it means a lot of things and it's funny
I have a lot of water metaphors uh like
in the book I talked about being a yacht
you know in the road to getting your
first job you're like this luxury yacht
that doesn't have a slip to Dock and
you're trying to build enough awareness
in the marina for people to offer you a
slip so you can get off the boat and
walk on land you know
um and then another one that I I say
often is um
you know sometimes when you're trying to
make that transition you're on two
surfboards but you can't ride them both
at the same time it's impossible and the
reality of that is you're gonna have to
choose which one you're gonna get on you
can't ride them both you're gonna have
to pick one and step off of one in order
to get to where you're going and so you
know this quote if you why if you ride
the wave long enough the tide always
turns
um is speaking to the idea of you know
for those of you who are trying and have
been trying to go after a singular goal
um
I can't remove being self-aware I know I
can't remove being
um uh you know being smart about the
business and being
open to feedback but if you take those
three things and include that as kind of
the back
the back end of this of this quote I
think that
over a long enough timeline with those
three things
um powering you you'll find your
opportunities
can it mean though that there can also
be a reversal of Fortune yeah I think I
think exactly there can definitely be a
reversal you can it you know if you're
seeing
you know hit after hit after hit or you
know everybody loves everything you do
every time that you release it or you do
it it's probably going to come a time
where it's not going to be as well
received
um and then at that point you know I
think then it just flips to the other
side and then you figure out how to how
to get out of that situation but
um you know
what do they say even a broken clock is
right two times a day you know like it's
just I I've found over my journey that
having things that remind me of
um
it's not Destiny or it's not
predetermined or it's not like you know
um
I'm not in some kind of
I can't think of the word I'm looking
for
um I'm not in some kind of like career
Purgatory you know what I mean like
there's ways to navigate the down times
and most of it's going to be about
having a positive attitude
if you had gotten into TV directing
right out of Sundance do you think you'd
still be directing today
no I don't I think if I got into
television directing right out of
Sundance uh
I would have made
too many mistakes to build a career
I think that
the first thing being TV and film
are two different
um they're two different mediums clearly
but making a film
whether you subscribe to the Arturo
Theory or not like it's the director's
medium and television is the writer's
medium and if you don't understand that
you're not going to farewell and I think
that over the 17 years that we've you
know identified between Sundance and
first job you know
I did a lot of branded content I did
some commercial work where I learned
that the product it's the products
medium you know what I mean it's the
it's the agency's medium and the Brand's
medium and learning that was something
that I could take to television and
understand like I'm gonna have ideas
here I'm gonna have pitches or
interpretations of a scene or a script
that
may not align with what the showrunner
wants and that's fine you know I won't
like go into my shell and say well I'm
not offering any more ideas because you
don't like them uh I know that there are
things that I'm not aware of because
I'm seeing episode 208 and you know that
this is going to end in season five in a
particular way in that great idea I have
doesn't compliment what you're doing you
know so
the understanding that reality and how
to finesse
um the relationships that the the
relationship dynamics that come with
that
um
you know having the skill to deal with a
variety of different types of
personalities on on a set cast crew
Executives
um and
having
the stamina and or
work ethic and work structure to
deal with the realities of Television
production which is driven by how fast
can you do everything you know to some
degree I wouldn't have been I would not
have been prepared for that
so then even though the weight was long
and here you are essentially helping
other people's dreams at the school
nothing wrong with that but
maybe you had seasoned you in the right
way definitely seizing me you know I I'm
definitely not campaigning for you know
17 years
um
before like uh you get hired to direct
but I I do think that there's
you know
there's
are things to learn before you can
really excel in particular professional
environments you know if you you didn't
ask me this but like if if I had to
identify it I'd say around based off of
the experiences that I had I'd say
around
2008 I was probably ready to do TV I
learned enough
about like people in politics you know
what I mean and and being a filmmaker
and delivering for a client I learned
enough I think by that time that I I
wouldn't have been you know
perfect but I would have I wouldn't have
stunk up the place and I would have been
able to get in there and kind of figure
it out
um and avoid big mistakes
well you'd been through 9 11 and then
then the recession was around that time
so it brought out probably interesting
sides to people in in stress like that
um so once you've kind of weathered
stuff like that you think you were just
like okay some pretty bad stuff has
happened in the world
and I think I know where my footing is
you know because if you're steering a
ship I.E a set that right there's drama
on not enough time somebody's mad or
whatever
um you know what's the worst that could
happen right right so so was there were
there certain Divine I don't mean to
assume that I know what happened I
apologize were there certain things that
happened that just got you ready for it
or was just
time of you know I think it's just time
you know like you do you do so many
projects and
Murphy's Law anything that can go wrong
will go wrong is gonna happen on every
project so then it's like
you have the thing you did and you're
like oh that little thing I thought that
was just gonna be a weekend that was the
project that I had a fire on set you
know fires happen okay or
um that was the project where I had you
know a a super egotistical person who
wouldn't come out of their trailer for x
amount of time okay dealt with that
um you know what I mean like uh and I
had to be the one to get him out
um this was the one where they pulled
out the money at the last minute and I
had so you just kind of you get you
begin to get
enough of a window into
you might as well just be open to the
world exploding you know it's like it's
like oh
pandemic right okay yeah like and not
not minimizing it but you do like get to
a point where like
I don't know what to what the day will
bring but I know that I'll be
able to
absorb it you know
um appreciate the moment and try and
find a way to get us home you know with
some semblance of what we set out to
accomplish today
and once you kind of get that you can
kind of
you know go with the flow
whereas maybe being slightly younger and
maybe different things it would rattle
you too much oh you'd be extremely
rattled and
there'd be you know self-loathing and
self-importance and why me and it's like
that doesn't that doesn't get
the Fang shot
sure it's fun to wallow in though it's
fun it is I mean that that's that's what
going home is for you know you go home
and then you tell your partner and like
can you believe what happened today and
they're like I'm uh I guess I have to
hear this for 30 minutes but you know uh
that's how it goes
what was the point of no return for you
not when you were inspired to be a
director but when you realize that you
could actually make a living doing this
hmm
so
well I realized that being a feature
filmmaker was not going to be a way to
make a living
the moment that I said that's a wrap on
my first feature because you know it was
the money was raised over uh it was the
script was written and the money was
raised over a six year period and the
amount of money I paid myself and the
other producers you know were all paid
equally was not even
like I barely have to file taxes for the
money you know what I mean like it was
very low and so
I'm like all right well that was six
years you know that was fifteen thousand
dollars over six years all right well
that's not gonna you know translate to
moving out of my mother's house and
whatever so
um
while I had a part I had a full-time job
at NYU but that was you know
thirty five thousand dollars a year it
wasn't much living in New York New
Jersey and so
um I said well what do I know that how
can I take this skill that I think I
have
um and find a way to
exploit it you know for myself and then
make money off of it and that was when I
started building the production company
to make videos
um and you know that was a journey of
um taking on more it was it was a pivot
moment like we've kind of talked about
it's like well these budgets are
small in their own way you know but
maybe if I wear more hats then I can
keep more of the money because the first
couple projects that I did it was like
well the editor is making more than
almost anyone because they're sitting
here
for the longest amount of time like like
really on the clock like four or five
days of editing
um while you know I'm shooting for one
day producers producing you know for
however long but they were becoming the
ones who were making the most money so I
was like well where if I edit then I'll
make more money if I shoot it then I'll
make more money if I produce it and
maybe bring on an assistant
I'll make more money and so
um I was constantly trying to figure out
how to survive economically as a
filmmaker but that was you know very
shortly after I finished the first
feature
um
over time you know as the company grew
and was doing all right with those
videos I look at it and I say well how
can I make more money
um so I was like we should be doing
campaigns for people because this
one-off video thing is I'm looking at my
Quickbooks at the time and I'm like well
all these budgets are in the same Strike
Zone I feel like the only way to get
more money is to change the cachet of
hiring us which I don't think is going
to happen without a big project or we
offer more services and charge more
because of the volume of it and you know
the irony of it is that that decision to
go toward campaigns led to
um some of the best performing years for
us and it was one campaign in particular
where I was like I'm gonna take my fee
and make a short film because by that
time it's 2014 I'm so far removed in my
mind from something that I've directed
for myself because
the feature film premium I directed in
o5 it finished its kind of distribution
trajectory by 07 I directed a feature
documentary in 0.708 and so now I'm six
years past when I could look at like
a version of what I could do as a
narrative director while having done
thousands of videos for clients and I
was like well let me make something for
me and uh this short film that I made
you know was the thing that got picked
up by HBO and got me into director
programs and led to TV directing and
still is a sample that I use now
um wow like six seven years later
because it was just it's it's a pretty
unique execution and concept so you know
um
I kind of was always I always had my
mind and my target on how to turn this
into a career
without it having to be Reliant upon
the models that everyone
believes are the only options
and so you were no longer working at NYU
or just part-time I was so I I was
working full-time at the desk job until
2012 and honestly that was the year of
my 10-year re 10-year anniversary at the
job and I was like I'm not gonna get no
disrespect to the job it was great but
personally I was like I'm not gonna get
y'all gave me a certificate for 10 years
you're not going to give me a watch for
25 like I'm not doing it so
um I left that in the 10th Year I quit
but uh I was
teaching at that time and I was like all
right well the teaching is not as much
of a guarantee but it gives me more free
time and I think that I can balance I
can use that free time to devote toward
building the production company then I
can teach to have that kind of smaller
guaranteed income
um and then you know
hopefully be able to push toward the
other you know my pers my passion
projects at the same time so I mean I
feel like what's interesting is I hear
myself talk or it may not be interesting
but
it was all very methodical you know it
was like I want to create but then like
well what how do I get there I'm not
just gonna sit here and like look at the
stars and you know daydream about how
great it would be to like make this
thing it's like what can I literally
wake up and do tomorrow to move the
needle toward you know this goal
so if you hadn't started that production
company then you may never have taken
some of that money and put it into the
short that yeah I wouldn't have had I
wouldn't have had thirty thousand
dollars to do it right wow yeah
when did TV become a major goal for you
so
TV became so I was
kind of peeking around the corner
looking at TV you know starting around
0708 I mentioned in my book one of my
buddies
um Seath man was a director friend who
had gone from indie films to television
and so I was like okay like he's a he's
a filmmaker to me you know and he's
going to TV and he's I know him
personally he's a cool guy so maybe
maybe there's something there maybe it's
not the the place where storytellers go
to die because you know in the past
people just TV TV
um
and so
I kind of always had my eye on him and
there's it's funny too because there's
like
I take I'm not a mystical kind of person
but I I I I guess I'm spiritual
um and I often
can't help but remark on like
the the Kismet of events sometimes and I
was walking down Melrose I parked on
Melrose to go somewhere and I was like
oh there's like something shooting and
they had like all their equipment and
like you know blocking this place of
business or whatever I was like do I
want to walk down Melrose or do I want
to walk through the alley behind the
Ally Melrose alley Melrose and I was
like Ally and so I walked down the alley
and out of the corner of my eye I see
the back of his head
oh and and I was like wait you know is
that you are y'all his name and he
turned around I was like yo that's crazy
I haven't seen him in years
um and just like the real like
I vacillated for like 10 seconds
deciding which way I wanted to go and if
I were had chosen the street I wouldn't
have seen them and if I had been a
second later
I wouldn't have seen him wow and then
that time
um this must have been 2012 and he was
like oh well you should um apply for
this HBO directing program so I applied
and I didn't get in but like I got a
little bit closer I had to get a DGA
um uh I had to get a DGA
um
director
recommendation and I was able to kind of
finagle that and I was like okay I'm
kind of getting closer even though I'm
still like on the outskirt and so
um you know I I applied to every program
that existed and
in
no and I'm sorry in 2015 after my short
that I made which was called Black Card
premiered at this film festival in New
York that was part of HBO
um
the gentleman who runs the Sony program
Brett King was at the screening and came
up to me and was like you know you
should apply
and I was like all right well you got it
and so of course it was like due for the
next day you know with a
letters of recommendation notary notary
public and like an essay and I was like
cool I've been I've been at the wire
before and um I got into the Sony
program and
the fall of 2015.
and that was when you know around that
time you know if I were
I kind of talked a lot earlier about
expectation and I think you know the
thing
to kind of
take away at least as far as how I think
about it is like
I'll do a thing
I know that it can potentially do all of
these things like maybe help me get into
TV or maybe you know get me an agent or
manager but then I kind of while I know
they exist and while I'll do my best to
prove to
create it in a way that helps me achieve
that then I kind of in my mind back away
from that because I don't want that to
be the
that the only way to put value on what I
do with it and so this short film was
very much that it was like all right I'm
gonna call my active friends I'm gonna
if there's anyone I know that can you
know maybe is more visible as an actor
than somebody else like maybe I'll see
if they'll do me a favor I'll put the
money where it matters on screen you
know
um and in a perfect world it'll help me
get in the TV but also I know that won't
happen that I mean I also know that's
not a guarantee I know it'll be a
guarantee for me to make this short look
at it and say okay this is like where my
talent Lies when no one's telling me
what to do and I'm making it for myself
and so that alone will be something that
I'll really get value from because then
I can learn and pivot again but it did
the thing that I had hoped for and it
got me into these uh it got me on the
radar of of people and
the business of making TV
and so I did the Sony program
2015 I did the HBO program 2016. I did
the Disney ABC program 2016 to 2018 and
I did the uh nbcu program in 20.
16 and through the relationships I was
building I was shadowing on shows
observing other directors and
um you know making sure that I was
building a network of folks who were
aware of me and what my goal was which
was to direct single camera comedy
sorry just a side note here you
mentioned your book did I just see your
book seconds okay so this is the book
um you know this photo was actually
taken on one of my return trips from La
back to New York after I'd moved out
here
um and a buddy of mine Eric Van selfden
took it before we got oysters because
that was our ritual
thank you but yes transitions a
director's journey in motivational
handbook
um and it's you know for me it's the
book
that I wish I could have read along the
Journey of the 17 years to getting paid
for narrative directing and I
distinguished that because I got I made
my own films I did uh client work for
people but that that was never someone
saying we want to hire you to direct
this like narrative
film or narrative TV show
um and and tell our story in this kind
of way with your with your skill set so
um you know it's a mixer of how to
self-help and inspiration and uh I think
it's it's useful for anybody in a
creative field but it's particularly
tailored for directors
you said you wish you'd had that book
yourself when you were just starting out
was there any tough love advice that you
have in that book that you wish somebody
had given you that maybe it doesn't
always sit well but then you think about
it and you're like yeah it applies
[Music]
you know I don't know if
I don't know if there's if I have tough
love in the book you know I think it's
um
I have to think about that because I
almost I'm almost compelled to
revisit my definition of tough love but
you know I feel like the
what I found I responded to in the books
that I read was
someone walking me through undeniable
facts
right so and for like for instance like
in the book I talk about going to the
Robert McKee seminar and people have a
lot of opinions on it but on the third
day he walks through or at least when I
took the the course scene by scene
analysis of Casablanca which is one of
my favorite films and so you walk
through it you break it down and then
for me what that did was like well at
the conclusion of this intricate
breakdown
of something where I'm nodding my head
for five hours like that that makes
sense oh that's great that's smart
I can't go back to my script
and
where it doesn't have those things that
I know work I can't say it's good enough
you know what I mean like I have to Now
work on my script and get it to the
point where with where whatever I'm
trying to do with this story matches the
execution of those things in a
Casablanca you know and I think in the
book the things that I talk about are
like you know if we agree that these are
the things then
how do we make sure that we
um
as artists and as business people
execute on those things you know so like
I even talk a lot about like the
technique and the psychology of the job
like it doesn't matter if you make the
best shot list in the world if you can't
navigate the personalities that come
out of the trailer and out of the office
and out of the van every day then you're
not gonna get one third of that shot
list and nobody's gonna remember what
you had planned
you know so
um
kind of just getting into the
nitty-gritty of that and maybe opening
opening the reader's eyes to those
things more so than like
um
you know maybe that maybe that's my
version of tough love yeah I was gonna
say that that sounds like some tough
love yeah maybe it is I like that you
know it is I I think of like Whiplash
or scary yeah like I'm not like you know
throwing throwing cameras at people
what are the four different levels of
being a director
again I'll preface there's there's no
higher level of importance per se it's
just like
um maybe it's not a totem pole maybe
it's a
you know it's a hieroglyphic wall that
goes left to right
um but I think you've got you've got
short films
um
and web series
um and in that space you're you're doing
things that are narrative but they're
they're going to take less time
um at least on the production end you
you could have you could do a story film
that takes a great deal of prep but
typically just with the amount of money
being spent and the nature of of the
content I think you've got short film
and web series
um I think then you've got
um commercials and music videos and
branded content and those are
maybe the distinguishing factor to
consider is that your your
outright selling a product right like
you're you're selling this you know
lotion you're selling this
um
uh some of the stuff I did in on in my
day was like this kind of
sponsored
documentary profiles where a brand might
want to interview a bunch of people
about what they do but like that type of
person is their direct customer you know
what I mean
um so it's it's much more of a of a
clear intent to sell and then uh I think
you've got television which is obvious
and then you've got feature films which
are obvious but the distinction being
um it's the medium for the director and
features and it's the medium for the
writer in TV
um and I think you know I would I would
offer that
trying all of them and being able to
direct in all of them
is a great skill set to develop because
you never know when one of them will be
called upon so as an example I did
um
the fifth episode of the final season of
Silicon Valley and so it's just like
it's this whole um
uh it was inclusive of an opening a Mad
Max kind of opening with Russ hanneman
and he's on a motorcycle and these women
in these kind of Mad Max cars are
chasing him and it's you know he's
blowing him up like with this hand
gesture or whatever and so
HBO being HBO was like oh let's go shoot
the thing so I was like oh we're gonna
actually shoot that so we took an extra
day outside of our production window for
the episode and shot that thing but then
there was also
um the characters sold a tequila in the
show called Trace Comas which the three
commas for being a billionaire and so
HBO in an ad agency partnered up to
actually sell that tequila so
the last part of that
five hour window where I Shot The Mad
Maxine was getting like 18 different
lines of him selling the Vodka which
would be used for online commercials and
it was like oh
I got you they were like how are we
gonna I was like I got this here's how
we'll shoot it you know but we'll
motorcycle will pull up he'll step off
I'll get each line and you know I'll get
half of them in this shot we'll reset
I'll get half in that shot it'll take us
about 10 minutes and it was like this
thing I had done it's kind of a running
theme that this thing I had done for all
these years was like now
a very great asset for what I was doing
at that moment
um and even like you know a lot of the
documentary stuff that I did you'd have
to walk into a room and say okay
um I'm thinking of uh from my
documentary on on the black tankers 760
first
we secured an interview with General
Colin Powell and we had 15 minutes of
his time and like that was like 14 plus
one to take a photo right and so got
down to Virginia and they're like you
can do it in this room and this room was
like the office furniture Cemetery
so
in 20 minutes or like get all that stuff
out of here let's leave that chair all
right we're gonna gel the windows I
think I saw a flag in the lobby let's go
get the flag from the lobby all right
there's a plant and doing that like has
helped me with production design when
walking into a location that
is a potential location for an episode
but
I have to Envision what it could look
like you know before I can you know say
I think this works or not like we don't
everything we walk into isn't what it
will ultimately be so I feel like I've
left the the the the farm and entered in
another world here but I there are all
these like takeaways from each of these
kind of four types of directing
that I think help you in your execution
of each other one
sure and then also two managing stress
and also having the confidence to say I
can do that you know and I'm sure
totally different world you know being
in Virginia getting maybe security
clearance to go somewhere and and
interview this man right versus what
seems like it would be a really fun set
in Silicon Valley but I'm sure there's a
lot of moving pieces and just right the
pressure but saying yes I can do that
that's really cool
yeah I mean so many great directors
started doing product you know yeah I
think it's a I mean if you can tell a
story in 30 seconds you know and be
aware of who your audience is be aware
of what the brand thinks of itself
you know because that's really the
guiding you know the North Star for how
you need to choose your
production design your wardrobe your
frame composition like all those things
if you can do that in 30 seconds
that's one type of story you know then
if you can take that and you actually
understand
you know human beings and their emotions
and their wants and needs and subtext I
think it it's it just makes you
very capable at doing this job
how much time did you spend at each of
those levels
one thing I often say is I'm platform
agnostic so that that's the flip side of
like that's the end game of delivery
right like I don't care if it's TV film
I guess quibby came and went but I
thought that was cool you know like web
is great with me like if it's a story
I'm interested in
where it ends up
fine with me
um
I have the same feeling for the you know
so-called levels that we're talking
about too like I would make a short film
next weekend if I had a script you know
because they keep I love there's a
different challenge of short filmmaking
which is it's about an event
and
something well you introduce a status
quo you introduce an event and you then
are left to imagine how the world you
know resolves itself after this event
has impacted the protagonist world or
life
um so I would do that
next weekend in between directing an
episode of Television you know
um I'm writing a script now a feature
script
um a co-writing a heist script that I
hope to make you know as soon as I can
finish it between directing these shows
and I still have a commercial agent so
I'm you know they're they all kind of
coexist to me
um but in the
in the
years where the goal was to get to TV I
would say it was you know feature
filmmaker
you know for well it was like feature
filmmaker and short filmmaker from 99 to
08. because I made my short they went to
Sundance I made another short that went
to a bunch more festivals in 04 I made a
premium in 761st in that time so I'm
kind of jockeying back and forth and
then from 08 to
2015 I made
a couple web series
I made uh
uh I didn't do any short I made another
short film that brought me back to TV
and I was writing feature scripts all
that time as well
um
and then now and you know let's say from
2015 to 2022 I've made a narrative
podcast you know that was going to be a
short film but with covet I couldn't
personally absorb the covet costs that
would be
um
put on the production in terms of
testing and everything that would go
with that so I was like well let's do a
narrative version of it an audio podcast
and I'm very proud of it
um what's it called sorry it's called
Wednesday morning
um and it's centered around uh it was
like a conversation around the 2020
election but in a very surreal kind of
discrete charm of the bourgeoisie
scenario
um and you know I got to work with my
wife who's an actor Kelly McCreary
um Coleman Domingo who's an actor
Spencer Garrett so it was great to just
you know the thing that I know I learned
from that project was It was kind of
easier to get people for the narrative
podcast
because it was and no one worked for
more than two hours
because it was like all right you're
12-2 in the studio and we'll get your
you know your character in this 50-page
script and we'll knock it out and so
that had my mind clicking of like I need
to write another narrative podcast
because then
that could maybe be something that
becomes intellectual property and then
can transition to a TV show like home um
like homecoming
um uh the the Sam esmail project
um
so anyhow uh I I feel like that for me
it's like
wherever a story can live
is the best place to put it and live
might be the different format you know
you might say well I can explore more of
this world or this character in TV
versus two hours with a film great you
might also be uh having to consider
money and so maybe the same idea and the
themes of that are better served in a
short film because you have five
thousand dollars and can make it short
which is better than an idea that you
just talk about so I think they're all
just like they're almost like lenses you
know like which lens is your favorite
well the one that gets the shot
what is the Classic Hollywood Story or
story structure that every filmmaker
slash writer should know I think uh
plenty of people have said it better
than me you know the hero's journey uh
Christopher Vogler
um I think understanding the archetypes
of well first that classic 3x structure
which is the setup the confrontation the
resolution and watching a cat and being
introduced to a character in their world
as they are experiencing it having them
deal with
whatever inciting incident challenges
them and makes them rise to action and
then obviously
um the resolution where we see how the
Journey of act two has impacted them and
will
affect their life and the lives of those
closest to them as they move
past the world of our film
um
you know I think that's something you
have to understand because it's
really where most storytelling exists
and how and then in turn how most people
are used to
absorbing and digesting a story so
learning what works before you break the
rules is important
um
I think that there are other you know
then then you just get into you know
more particular understandings of
character and structure
um
that
hero's journey book by Vogler is great
because he breaks down like you know the
character archetypes from
um you know the I might misquote some of
these people but like you've got allies
you've got
um you've got the shape shifters you
know the people who uh are introduced as
allies perhaps but then they have
ulterior motives
um whether driven by plot or driven by
character like all of these things are
are helpful to make you kind of look at
the world of your story and begin to
like pick up the right tool to craft it
into something that best
realizes whatever your themes and your
points are that you're trying to try and
accomplish
um
so I feel like that's that's really the
key
um then if you are
I think that Robert McKees book
obviously has like a really great story
triangle that was just one element of
the book that but it was very
um I'm a visuals person and so I think
in his triangle he has like you know at
the top of the triangle is um
the Classic Hollywood narrative that
we're talking about now at the bottom is
um the anti-hero anti-hero you know like
a Travis Bickel and taxi driver and then
at the bottom on the other side is the
uh the multiple character story like a
magnolia or anything Robert Allman and
the joke that he makes is as you move
down the triangle your audience gets
smaller you know and I think that's true
you know unless you have a movie star in
it and you can make Magnolia you know
or crash or you know whatever it might
be right
um but yeah understanding those things I
think is important to being able to
have some agency and control over the
story while still you know being
responsive to what the characters tell
you needs to happen
did you watch Casablanca again after you
took McKee's class oh yeah I've probably
I've watched it often yeah okay yeah and
did you see it with new eyes once you
once you took his class definitely I saw
it with new eyes you know you start
there's there's like
I can enjoy something
while watching
watching you know the sausage being made
you know what I mean like
I can watch like oh I see what they're
doing I see why they did that in that
scene and that was still you know it was
very economical it was still character
driven and that was a smart way to do it
in 1941. you know what I mean uh or even
now like I'm watching uh
we're watching Top Boy on Netflix and
there are just certain things that kind
of have to happen in the story and when
they happen I'm watching and I'm like
that was a very smart way to do
something that has to happen and so when
you know the mile markers that's when
you can begin to you know add your own
perspective add your own sauce you know
your old your own interpretation and
make it unique but you can't if you
don't know that that mile marker is
happening you know you can't do it at
all you know a bad example would be like
if you were a vegan you have to know
what certain elements are doing in a
non-vegan dish to then say we need this
thing to accomplish what cheese would
accomplish you know what I mean and so
like
the architecture of Storytelling you've
gotta you've got to have a you got to be
fluent
when you went to direct uh was it some
of the later episodes of you of you I
did
um episode 307 and 308 so that was
um
third season episode seven and eight out
of ten total episodes
so did you go and re-watch
and I really study who these characters
are because they're very very clear
interesting characters fascinating yeah
with any show I'll go and I mean some
shows make it impossible because they
have too many seasons but
um with you I watched every I probably
watched every episode twice
um because I'm watching for
um style I'm watching for and that could
be from the writing to the to the tone
how they handle different moments
whether it's you know violence or sex or
um you know uh camera
uh nowadays how are you applying text
you know and then being on a phone
because that's a whole other thing you
know
um and I'm just trying to digest
it's like the information's already
there for me to to start from so I'm
just trying to take it all in
um a lot of times I I might notice like
oh well you used to do this thing in
season one and you know it's not really
happening anymore
um is that like why did you step away
from that and sometimes you're like oh
that was the thing we hated or maybe
they might say oh you know what that was
cool
I don't know why we aren't doing that
anymore let's do that you know so I'm
trying to like information is key
um and then you know I'll read any and
all scripts up to my episode because
some things won't be finished
so you know in a scenario like that you
might have
I could watch maybe two episodes you
know 301 and 302 and then I've got to
read three four five and six to know
where we are in the story and then
figure out what
is happening in my episode and then I've
got to have questions about where it's
going so I I'm aware if I'm setting up
anything in particular for the final two
sure and a lot of chance meetings in a
show like that and and a lot of
characters uh lying and not revealing
themselves which is sort of you know me
the audience is privy to it but the
other characters aren't right and that
show you know last little inside for for
the directors out there that show was an
interesting challenge that I didn't
foresee which is
blocking
for Joe for Penn badgley's character
where
when we're in his mind and he's got his
thoughts blocking in a way where he can
have business and be moving around a
room so those those thoughts can kind of
be private
and he's not compelled to engage with
the other person
so it's like if I'm if if two people are
looking at each other it's a little
weird to have this monologue going that
this voiceover on him while he's really
talking to somebody over here but let's
say I make him take a walk over here get
a plate out of the cupboard and his
backs to her he comes back here puts the
plate down and a fork and a knife and
then he looks up that could cover all
the vo of his inner thoughts and so it
was a lot of like really having to think
like the actor and come up with pitches
that would work for that reason
um and so I'm sure that'll be a skill
that I'll take to something else that I
can't predict
we're hoping we can imagine two
filmmakers one is an artist and she
spends five years or so focusing only on
the craft of filmmaking and nothing else
she learned story camera angles lenses
blocking and so on so then we have the
other filmmaker and this filmmaker
spends the same five years but only on
the business and
um she studies the market financing
distribution budgets networking Etc
which of these two filmmakers do you
think will have a longer lasting career
I would say that the person spending if
if our if two of these two people are on
are one in the same right
um
like it's it's it's Pete and Bizarro
Pete right
and you've got
um I think the the version of this
person that is focused on understanding
The Craft
and is May and I'm going to add an
element of of a constant of they're both
making thanks
um I would say that the person studying
the craft is going to
um
have a longer career
because they are likely at some point to
make something impactful
they'll they'll be able to take what's
in their heart and put it
on videotape you know I'm going to say
on film but on tape or in a final
product that best represents what they
felt when they started the project
because that's really the Divide right
The Divide is I have this feeling I want
to make this thing
and for a while
the execution doesn't match the
authenticity of the feeling
and then you get to a point where you've
built up enough skills to get pretty
close to how you felt
in how you deliver it for the audience
to feel that way too
the person who is making things
but maybe leaning more into the studying
of the business and and all of that you
know I feel like
the real
asset in the industry is in voice you
know and and is in perspective and so I
feel like
they may know what they may learn what
they're supposed to do or you know
here's
um here's how you do it or you know
but I think
if it's in Broad strokes and in not like
spending the additional time that the
other person is and really mastering the
Craft
um I think I think this person wins okay
what if this person becomes so you know
that their voice is so unique and they
just make this incredible film but
they're naive to the business
is that is that something that could
take them out in some sense I mean it
could take them out I mean you know in
the perfect world they meet a they meet
a really honest agent and manager and
lawyer who is really interested in
nurturing their talent and you know
cares about their
you know or tailors their representation
to the individual you know but
the likelihood of having to rely on that
I think is is uh a gamble I wouldn't
take
you know so like
you know and all not it seems it seems
like the right thing to do but that's
kind of I feel like my book is actually
for the person you're talking about
you know like my book is for the person
who is spending all their time trying to
be creative make XYZ work know how to
pick the right lens and tell the story
in the right way you know but I'm kind
of in your ear saying that's not enough
though
don't forget about this you know have
you read the trades you know and I think
it's the the superhero of this is like
you know is the is the marriage of of
the two people that you're presenting
you know how can you take
uh you know and that's not 50 50.
sometimes it's it's 70 30 because it or
you know it's 70 Business 30 creative
because now I'm in development and I got
to talk to people and I've got to like
have meetings and meetings and then now
I'm making this thing and it's 80 20.
you know now I'm I'm
the creative director and I've got other
people around me taking care of the you
know people management and business of
it and I need to be in that space like
it's a I guess the the real
the real revelation of your question is
the fact that you know you have to kind
of be all these things in my mind if you
want to have the best opportunity at
preserving your intent
um
and it's no different you know than even
like in indie films now they talk about
this producer of marketing and
distribution like who's working on you
know social media things well before
you've even gotten the money you know
because it's going to be a value add
down the line
um and I remember I talked to one person
on a dock I was working on he said that
you know people complain about the
middleman or the middle person right and
you know oh I there are these
Gatekeepers and you know we can't do
this we can't do that but the reality of
it is is with the democratization of all
things now
You could argue that the middle person
the gatekeeper is you
and you have to change your
connection to what you're willing to do
because theoretically you could take
your iPhone and shoot it you could take
your computer and get some software and
edit it you could release it on your
website that you designed you could
Market it through your social media
campaigns which you manage like there's
no one stopping you anymore and so
there's no other there's no better time
than now to marry those two profiles
together and I think if you look at the
filmmakers and the storytellers who are
really doing well in today's world
that's exactly what they've done in your
book do you talk about do you have a
chapter about sort of people that don't
want to focus on the business
um I don't have no I don't have a
chapter dedicated to that but I I do
speak specifically to
representation securing it and what you
should look for in that team because
to your point you know at the end of the
day or not at the start of the day too
um your reps get paid when you work
so they work for you they don't actually
send you a check from anywhere connected
to you know their job they're sending
you the check from the people who paid
you to do the show that you did and so
um
really being con thoughtful it's a
partnership it's a marriage like you
have to you have to marry the right
people you know and you have to know
you have to be clear about what you want
um you have to be
you know I think it works best when
you're aware of how the business works
because then they recognize that you are
also you know perhaps more of a partner
than some of their other clients in your
own career and you know at the end of
the day like you you've got to take the
reins on on the business of you
how is it possible that you read a
screenplay what 50 times before you
shoot it yeah so when I get a you know
my perspective on
directing is I'm trying to be the
authority on the material and most of
the things that I do that are you know
in the feature or short space I've
written or I've been part I've been a
part of that process from the beginning
I've given notes from the beginning I'm
aware of all of the kind of mental
gymnastics that are behind those you
know 10 pages or those 120 pages and so
when I get a script for TV
because I haven't been privy or had the
privilege of seeing that process
I'm trying to get
a very thorough understanding of what's
on the page so I can begin to
deconstruct what I think that process
may have been
so that means I'm reading the script as
many times as I can in as many different
environments as I can
um I'm reading the script as different
crew people
um this is just my personal
um
take I like to read it as the
cinematographer I like to read it as the
Wardrobe custom designer I like to read
it as the production designer because
then
and I read it as a director last because
I feel like all of those things help me
get into the mind of
um a the people I'm collaborating with
but like B I get an understanding of
what I have at my disposal as the
Director so I could read a scene in on
the third reading maybe I'm like oh you
know what now I'm thinking about it as
the actor because I've done all the
other thinking and I'm like oh what if
the actor wants to sit down
um in this scene well I'd love for them
to have a chaise lounge uh versus like a
chair you know so now you know that
third reading revealed a Furniture
selection you know what I mean
um or if I'm reading at home versus
reading at a cafe when the world was
open like that
um sometimes just being around a bunch
of people changes what I'm digesting so
um it's important for me to do that I
also make a spreadsheet where I take all
the story lines and this comes from
another book on directing I'll take all
the story lines and put them in a
different column so I can have a
top-down look at the architecture of the
entire episode
and it also doubles as a brief refresher
for me on set should I need it or if an
actor is like you know well where was I
in the last scene and I'll be like oh
well that was where doing Scene 40 now
but in scene 22 you did XYZ and then
they can be like okay great I know where
I'm coming from
so
um
being as thorough as possible is the is
the is the goal
interesting so you would digest a script
differently in let's say a busy coffee
shop here in La than you would let's say
in a library yeah
and I think it's just it's kind of hard
to
explain with any
value that's not like
it just feels different but like you
know you you might be paying more
attention
in one of those you know settings than
you had in another or maybe you heard
something in the background that
triggered a subconscious thought about
something you're experiencing here I
don't know yeah I can't put it I can't
put like a thumb on it or
point to what it is exactly but I do
think I know for sure like I've it's
been
on subsequent readings where something
is revealed
um and so I'm trying to
really give myself as many opportunities
to find out find those Revelations
before I'm on set
and as the Director lasts you where the
director's hat reading it last that's
interesting because I feel like I can't
I have to I have to I'm I can only
direct something that's been figured out
like otherwise like I'm I'm putting
camera in random places that are not
driven by actor or like some other level
of like thematic thought that is
Tethered to story you know because I
mean I could I could very easily be like
oh yeah I'll put the camera here I'll do
that that uh we will swoop around but
then like you know as you read it you're
like I'm I'm gonna treat that storyline
like this actually and
I have to I have to settle into it a
little bit more
do you ask the screenwriter for story a
b story C story or how many story lines
are in the episode
I
when I get the script I I extract them
myself I try and identify them
um as you know oh the a story is
um
you know this character is
having a crisis of confidence about
something at home and then the B story
is
um this thing at work and then the C
story is
one of the kids is going through XYZ and
then the d-store you know and I'm sure
sometimes I'm probably maybe adding a
storyline you know because I might I
might really carve them out uh to be
distinctive but maybe in their mind
something is
a similar storyline you know but uh yeah
just go in and carve it out
um and when I I have time I'll try and
give each scene a name
um now I have less and less of that time
now but I try to give each scene a name
so I'm like as I step into directing it
it's like this is you know
uh so-and-so's retribution or you know
whatever it might be so I can kind of
have a guiding principle for how I'm
talking about the scene to the actors or
the crew how I want to shoot it and just
have a you know something that's helping
me make have a point of view because at
the end of the day I think
I'm there to apply in a point of view
and a point to apply a point of view
from which to
shoot and direct the scene
right because we were talking about
inventing Anna um but before we when we
were setting up and so I guess you could
say well you know we're learning about
this journalist and she's there and she
doesn't want to do another me too story
she wants to do something else and she's
at war with her editor
and she's just fascinated by this the
story of this woman and she's having a
crisis at home I guess I don't know if
she's going to have a baby or she's
trying to or something and she's not
even sure she wants to right and then
she just becomes obsessed with this
woman almost as a way to avoid her own
life really in a lot of ways so yeah
that's those were basically the three
stories and I'm sure there's other parts
to it but yeah that's right you had me
thinking of that just because yeah in
different episodes there were probably
other characters where it was like and
this is the D story and this is the E
you know because some other supporting
character was important to because it's
always it's always this point
Counterpoint to whatever the theme is
it's like here is you know this idea
represented at its best via this
character and here's this idea
represented at its you know perhaps
worst through this character and
the cocktail of the entire episode
hopefully says
and here's what we think about that
right and maybe that's when she meets
the other people that knew Anna right
okay that makes sense yeah now I see
what you're talking about how do you
figure out how many story lines
are in an episode
um yeah I mean it's just carving them
out as I so I mean like functionally
like as I read the script and this is
well
this is probably into
you know
second or third reading like the first
one is I try and let that be
uninterrupted and purely as a reader
um so I can kind of just say oh okay
here's the story you know that it's is
being told I don't want to start saying
like oh that's funny oh that's witty or
you know making notes on I think that's
a high angle shot like I just want to
read it uninterrupted but second or
third episode I'll go through and when
making that spreadsheet
you know first scene is usually what the
episode's about right so okay boom I'll
take that second scene
um I'll just go scene by scene until all
of the
until I and and as and as a new
storyline is introduced I'll give it a
new heading
more often than not I don't think you're
going to get out of act one
without having been introduced to all of
them
you know and so and it's in television
and some of the
some of the shows will
um
literally tell you this is the cold open
this is act one end of act one
Others May do
dip to Black you know which is basically
the same thing
um and so you know like in in that
act one or you know in that first area
of scenes before it dips the black
that's probably going to be all of the
story lines that are at play because it
moves so quickly that you're not likely
to have a new storyline introduced in
Act 2.
so you have like an Excel document
already sort of like plugged in and then
you just for each new project you just
plug the okay interesting
and so you do that fairly soon after
you've read the script a few times
I do it fairly soon
um you know like I mentioned it's useful
for being on set but it's also useful in
prep because in prep
I'm out on I'm in a van or I'm
self-driving and we're going all these
different locations and now instead of
having to thumb through the script I can
go to my spreadsheet and say oh yeah
okay this is that scene though and then
on a location scout I can glance really
quickly remind myself of why we're here
you know and what what we need and then
move through the process pretty
efficiently
okay and this is going to be different
than a shot list yes much different yeah
yeah do you do anything that's more
tangible that's not on the iPad or your
laptop
um no you know the the driver before
covid I used to have I used to have a
script
and I would have the shot list that I
would print out from Hollywood shop
designer
and that would be a function of getting
the floor plans from you know that I
mean that I can show you
um
that would be a function
of getting the floor plans
from
resume editing yeah that would be a
function of getting the floor plans from
the production designer uh and then
implementing them into
Hollywood shot designer and then
blocking it so as an example
um
this is a floor plan from a location a
club location
um
in West Adams for a scene from insecure
and this was uh three
characters
walking up to a club uh and I'm sorry
two characters walking up to a club uh
Issa and Daniel she's blue he's red
um they find a bouncer at the door
bouncer one and bouncer two are our gray
folks and then we had
um another character
um I didn't put the name here but that
she knew from high school who walks up
and helps get them into the club
and so you know I've got
um I don't necessarily put everything in
here but I'm you know I at least have
the broad Strokes
um I had this wide from across the
street that tracked with them as they
walked past the line of people thinking
that they would walk up and get in of
course they don't and they get they're
met with security
um I think this wide from
uh it says why from across symmetrical
tighter for crowd exit that was
something that I got at the end of the
night it was for the end of the sequence
but I got it
you know you shoot all the exteriors at
one time and then uh
I knew I would have I would bring them
back on this Steadicam shot in the green
landing and over
the bouncer back to them and then I
would have you know coverage and then
coverage going both ways and so in the
in the pre-covered days I would have
these all printed out
um
and I would have my script printed out
and I would just kind of walk around
with all of these I'd share those with
the ad and with the DP and obviously
things change you know some scenes go
exactly as planned but it's mostly to
have a plan and to be able to have the
crew prep towards an idea because even
if the coverage all changes this is this
is where the actors are going to be
um and so uh
but with covid in the beginning there
was a commitment to not to being
paperless to not handing like when when
people were washing their mail you know
like it was uh no Productions were
handing out scripts so everything became
um electronic and so another app that I
use scriptation became my go-to and so
it's great because the script's in there
now I don't have to have a script I can
update new drafts with my notes from a
prior script and instead of having that
app I showed you Hollywood shop designer
I would just add a page
into the script
take a screenshot of the plan and just
draw on it in the script so then
everything just became one document
and so that's called shot Lister that's
called Hollywood shot designer shot
designer I'm sorry and um so you can
kind of just plug in the exact sort of
what that you said Issa Rae was read her
character right and then the the other
character was blue and then gray were
the friends and stuff so you can assign
the sort of the yeah there's a bunch of
like icons for characters they have
lights they have different props they
have cars and motorcycles and kind of
all the basic things that would pop up
and you can just say you know and if you
want you can animate the cameras but at
a certain point you know I I feel like
it becomes a little too much because
you'll figure you have to leave room to
figure it out on the day but it's a
great device for prep so people can have
an idea of where the production should
be leaning and so and everybody gets a
copy of that uh well in this case the DP
and ad because they're filtering it out
to you know the camera department and
then the ad is
uh it's helpful for the ad to be able to
manage how much time will be needed for
a particular scene
but actors and backgrounds I mean I
might show it to them if they wanted to
but overwhelmingly
um
comes down to the communication which is
the again like the tough part of the job
like you know being able to relay what
you want being able to do it in a way
where you're not
um a dictator you know and you like you
like in my mind I've got this whole
scene figured out because I I can't show
up without having done that now it
doesn't mean I'm right but I've got it
all figured out and I've got to allow
the actors and the cinematographer
everybody to have their time to
find it and also feel collaborative in
it and so it's like finding out finding
developing the methods to do that
you know
that's the journey I think of the
director
how much of directing at the highest
levels in this business is about skills
you have at your craft versus people
skills and politics so I had I had a I
had a meeting for a show or for a
network rather last week and we got into
a conversation about soft skills right
um which are what we were kind of
talking about earlier like you can have
the best shot list in the world but the
soft skills help you get somebody out
the trailer help you convince somebody
that the work they're doing is great
help you you know
deal with uh
whatever scenario that might arise right
um I think that
a director without humanity is going to
be is going to have challenges doing
their job because you know I think back
to
being younger and you're just so focused
on
gotta get the shot like uh why it was if
everybody would just come here and do
what I'm ready to do we could get you
know I mean like like you're just it's
all about getting this thing done you're
feeling the burdens and the pressure of
the money you know because you're
probably over over leveraged and you're
tired and why won't they just do what I
want them to do and you know
that
that is also natural when you don't have
the tools to you know deal with the
pressures of the job but I think
as you learn them you do recognize that
um
those soft skills are are key you know
and and look you know I've done I've
done
episodes as a as a guest director where
I've been brought to a show to direct an
episode and that is at that point they
think that you can do it they think
you're competent and you can keep you
won't mess up their show right
um then there comes a point where like
now I'm a producing director on a show
and a co-executive producer now they're
saying well
we think you're someone that can help
work with all the directors will hire
can help you know be a liaison between
post and the producers for the creative
now that's a different person
in terms of skills right
um then there's the you know pilot
director you know like I have a pilot
I'm attached to that's a different thing
because they're looking for someone who
can do both of those things while also
you know maybe have more owner have a
have a little more ownership of it as a
director than a guest director because
you're creating a look for a show
um so you're marrying like so many
different parts of of your of of what
you do
um and knowing when and when and why to
apply pressure I think is the is the
um directors you know challenge
can you tell us about how to politic and
what is that
I think you know
how to politic I think is is that same
kind of answer like knowing when to
apply pressure some things when I was
when I was when I was working as faculty
I used to be in a lot of meetings a lot
of meetings and I would just kind of
I had a joke where I was like
people can talk about whatever they want
until it sounds like there's about to be
a policy change
that's going to affect the job I do I
can sit here and be
unmoved because some I don't know why
that person may be performing what
they're doing right now maybe they're
making a stance for some reason I have
no idea about and this person has
tension with them and that person always
says something and this person doesn't
want to you know reveal what they don't
what you know all these things but the
moment it sounds like there's about to
be a new pile of work on my desk well
now uh I have a thought you know and so
you I just kind of learned like
when is
be like read the room
and see what's really happening and
whether or not something impactful is
happening something performative is
happening you know
and whether or not what you might
be getting ready to say matters or is
going to have an impact
um
and I mean I I think that was a that was
one of the best things that again I
didn't know I was learning but I think
that was one of the best things I
learned being in like a university
environment and so
I try and you know
maintain vigilance in
reading a room and seeing what's
happening and whether or not you know
and and
measuring my response
um to get what I'm looking to get and
that's not you know I'll flip this and
say that's not to say that everything is
a manipulation and everything but you
know
I can I can remember one time being
called into a trailer
hair makeup trailer
um with like you know show Runners star
actor actress and like hair makeup and
I'm being asked all these questions and
I'm like
what's happening and it was about a
scene that we had agreed to shoot a
certain way and then I'm listening and
listening and listening and I'm like oh
what I'm recognizing here because I'm
not being I'm not like
uh like being super responsive to like
the fact like first off we've already
talked about this you know I mean like
I'm saying I can talk talk talk because
I know the more you talk the more I'm
going to get something that I can begin
to understand
and you know I don't know if it was
three minutes or or ten it felt like 30
but I was like oh it sounds like to me
and my guess here that this actress
wants the body double but doesn't want
to ask for it
and
I'm pretty sure that's what it was and I
said you know well why don't we just do
the body devil Boba because there were
all these things connected it seemed to
her for that request you know what I
mean and like
um
we I I noticed that our relationship
kind of got that much better after that
and I was just reading the room and
trying to like I could say we've talked
about it three times but like does that
matter
you know so
I think it's it's being it's allowing
people to be people
you know what I mean and and trying to
um
be aware of like the multiple ways you
can get
to an end result that
maintains the Integrity of what you set
out to do
so there's not just subtext on the page
there's there's some on set too oh yeah
production show is that how do other
people show us that we actually don't
have the soft skills we thought we had
well that that makes me reach for the
book oh good okay because in in the book
in the in the introduction
um you know because
as with anything I'm
you write something and and for me I
want to go like well what
will make you listen to this right and
so in the introduction
um
yeah here we go
um there are three questions that uh
I'll just I'll actually read you because
it's not it's not a long thing uh in
2014 after six unsuccessful years of
unrealized efforts to break into
episodic television directing I asked
myself a series of probing existential
questions
and I think these three questions answer
the question about like what if you
think you've got soft skills and but you
know things aren't happening I asked
what's not working
what if everything I'm doing is wrong
and how can I pivot
so if you think that you've got those
skills but you ask yourself what's not
working and you look and you see what my
films do well
but like
this isn't happening maybe it's that
maybe I don't know the industry and the
mechanics of the business well enough
you know maybe I keep making films that
if I had read the trades I could have
seen that there were already two films
in development about that thing and mine
was never going to compete you know I
think that kind of those kind of
questions that
demand self-reflection
um help you
avoid getting mired into something that
you think is what it's not
can we learn soft skills can we learn
how to I mean we all think we know how
to work with other people but sometimes
life shows us that that's not the case I
think we can learn them I had to learn
them
yeah and like I mean I think I had some
handful of them you know
um but to your earlier question like
like if I would have
been offered TV coming out of out of
Sundance
and it would have been different
you know and so I think and I and over
the next you know years years and even
you know I learned the new soft skill
last week I'm sure you know
um I think that I think the thing it's
not the it's not the ability to learn
it's the appetite to learn
right because we can we can keep
learning until the day we die you know
but if we think that we've we've got it
all figured out then
it's off the table
once you establish yourself as a working
television director do you interview for
your next job oh yeah yeah you do a lot
of it you know once so it's a lot of
General meetings before you ever get
hired which is basically
the are you well I get along with you
are you crazy meeting you know what I
mean like
um and you do a lot of generals so a lot
of so more and more people can say oh
yeah
competent person it's a nice enough
person like
you get what we're doing over here at
our company maybe you know and somewhere
along the line
someone's going to say okay we're going
to hire you like Kenya Barris did for me
in 2017.
um and so then you begin to build your
resume hopefully you get invited back to
a show because that's kind of
so if the general meeting went well and
people were like okay talented not crazy
you get what we're doing over here
getting invited back is the affirmation
of that oh they must not have been crazy
they must have really done a nice job
and they must have really understood
what the show wanted
um the
kind of industry not wisdom but saying
or whatever thought is that when you see
someone with a bunch of one episode at a
bunch of different places it's like well
why aren't you ever going back right
and so
you get invited back then you do more
and more shows
um the beauty of of today that might
mask uh the invited back is that a lot
of shows are doing block episodes where
like you like I did two at one time so
it might look like you got invited back
um but once um you do enough work
the work itself begins to be what vets
you so someone may say oh we're thinking
about or even for like the shows that
I'm unaware where we are looking for
directors you'll say oh they've done XYZ
and you can just look and tell that
they've
have the skill set to do your show
um then you'll probably call
around and see if there are people that
you think people that you know know that
person that can you know give you a
little bit more insight into them so
that's where the reputation and and and
that Community is really important and
then after that you always have some
kind of Zoom which is maybe less of a
meeting
um
like it might they'll get to know you
and you'll probably speak really
specifically to the show so it's not a
general it's like about this show
um and at that point you know I feel
like you're probably
it's probably your job to lose
so I guess the long answer to your
question is at this point
I'll either get an offer or I'll get
um like an outright offer they want you
to do these this block episodes because
they've done enough vetting that they
feel like they don't need to
um speak directly to me or they already
know me or
they want to have a meeting on zoom and
uh
if it's at that point they're probably
highly considering me for the job and
that's the final step
what are a few do's and don'ts for a
general
maybe don't don't speak too much you
might say the wrong thing or I you know
I think the I think meetings are you got
to find a way
to still be yourself
in an unnatural environment you know
because it's it's kind of like speed
dating you know what I mean and so I
feel like
the dues are
to be very clear on
have a very clear
and concise way to deliver your your
backstory and who you are your bio your
origin story to be very clear on why you
want to do the show you know hopefully
who you are and what you've done
connects to the show so then it becomes
to make almost perfect sense why you
should be directing it you know
um
don't come in there and be unaware of
the person you're talking to
um there are so many opportunities to
find a connective thread that Google
will help you with whether it's oh you
went to NYU or oh you're from New Jersey
or
um
you worked with the person I know you
know on so-and-so project and they say
hi you know like any little thing that
you know that's not going to get you the
job but it it begins to warm things up a
little bit
um and I think be be clear about
um
you know what you offer to the show and
ask questions I think to come in and not
have any questions
um
Belize a person who's not very curious
because with with those questions you
gain information
you know
um not that I'm the I'm the model for it
but like I'm thinking like like you
asked me a question about this person
versus that person and I'm like well
what is that person's goal because that
that's going to help me kind of
you know answer the question and
sometimes in a meeting asking questions
helps you figure out
what you might not want to say
and just absolute don'ts
um well yeah it's the don't come in
there unprepared you know whether that's
in understanding the person in front of
you and understanding
um it their bio or some portion of it
that you can because sometimes I've come
across a few people where it's like you
scrub yourself from the internet somehow
and I don't know how you did that but I
don't know anything about you
um so their personal bio their
um their bio here at this job what did
they have the power to do
right
um are they the person who hires are
they the person who weeds out and then
you know this is the meeting that gets
you to the next person who may actually
be able to hire like you know uh what
projects are they proud of is has
anything been greenlit recently or you
know did a show just Premiere last week
watch that show and be able to talk
about it you know because that shows
that
you're invested in what they do as well
um because at the end of the day I think
the way I try and view working
professionally in a world full of
collaborative creative people is I want
as many people to make their projects as
possible
I'm here to be a support for that
whether it's maybe it's feedback or
maybe it's directing an episode or you
know maybe it's a go get them champ you
know but uh
providing that type of energy I think is
something that folks are
happy to have around them
and lastly how early is too early
for what for to show up at one of these
meetings oh how early it's too early to
arrive I mean
you know
make sure you're there on time uh I I
get I try and get there 30 minutes early
but then you won't see me in the lobby
until you know five minutes before you
know what I mean maybe maybe 10.
10 is a good amount of time because I
wanna you do want to give yourself time
to get in
you know sit down you know reap you know
run through whatever you might have
prepared again sometime it might be
going into the bathroom and stretching
out a little bit or whatever whatever
you need to do
um but don't don't walk in there at 128
for 1 30
um Because unless you've got some
abilities that I don't have to smoothly
transition to meeting mode
you don't go in expecting to be hired
instead you go in to make it impossible
for them not to hire you
how is that different so you know
the way I view it is and this is like
I think I think a big takeaway from the
book is that I'm I'm big on
viewing things through the prism that I
can control right and and viewing things
in a way that
you know
really prevents
getting beaten down by the realities of
of what we do in a world where you're
selected and or not selected for reasons
known and unknown
um fickle and and arbitrary and
sometimes spot on and so
um
my thought was when I was trying to get
jobs and and I I still carry it with me
is that I understand that there are
people who will be easier to hire for a
particular job and that happens now
um you know
but
my job is to come into this meeting and
make it
the most challenging decision for them
to not hire me
so what does that mean
I'm going to come in and tell my bio
origin story and it's going to be you
know concise it's going to be
um you know whatever funny it's gonna
I'm gonna give you the best me that's
honest but designed to you know connect
with what we're
talking about here is a project as
possible
um I'm going to show you that I've done
my research
I'm going to speak about the show
because I've watched enough to develop a
point of view that's informed I'm going
to be interested in asking questions
about it I'm going to let you know
outright how much I want to do this show
um you know all the things that make it
where you're like looking at the grid of
people up for it you know you may have
somebody that's done more
um work than I have in this particular
genre or just at all but maybe they
weren't as
exciting a meeting
maybe they didn't outright tell you they
want the job maybe they didn't you know
get into a really deep dive conversation
into the show
you know and I understand why you would
still hire them over me if you know for
all the reasons that make hiring what
hiring is but I want that to be a tough
decision
and my thought was if I if I can
build
of Rolodex a database a spreadsheet full
of meetings where that was the end
result at some point somebody's gonna be
like all right this is the right one
for him
I see so yeah so then it's kind of
nebulous that's like I'm going there to
get hired versus I'm going to make sure
that they can't not hire me because that
seems like it checks more boxes I feel
like that's clear to me and it's the
actor's audition right like the actors
audition is you can't you can't audition
to get the job like that if you do that
you're going to
be depressed because how many jobs are
you going to get you have no control
over that you know but what you can do
and this is from me on the other side of
the table like watching auditions like
what you the auditions that land are I
can tell that you had a perspective
you made a choice you prepared and you
executed on that choice and whatever
those three things were you gave you
provided a tape that was your best
presentation of those things and then
ain't nothing else you can do about it
you know what I mean like we can debate
oh like we might say oh well she's you
know the person that we've already cast
for her sister she doesn't look anything
like her and it's a big stretch because
that's important and so like no we don't
hire that person and they may have been
the best person but you know there's
another reason why they might not have
gotten a job
and so
you know directors are auditioning in in
a similar in in somewhat of a similar
way
um and just taking the reins and making
sure like you show them what you can do
show them who you are and let them
decide but make it hard
and how do you say I would love to take
on this opportunity or is that what you
say that's what I would say
outright
so so maybe two other people might think
that but that's too passive and they
just go okay great so yeah just please
keep me in mind like you basically let
it be known let me know I want this
because there's and and you know my
estimation is that
on on this fictitious sheet of paper of
names that are that are up for something
you know maybe one or two of them are
doing it because their agent said they
should
all right and maybe it's attractive to
the people behind the show because oh
it's so-and-so you know or maybe they
you know used to be so-and-so like
cool
but like I'm gonna come in and I'm gonna
there will be no doubt you know um and
in a world of meetings where folks are
having 40 meetings a week like these
things begin to
stand out
and lastly do you send a follow-up email
or even a card
um I well it depends you know sometimes
I have there are a lot of relationships
where
I don't have any of these folks
information because the Reps at the
meeting and then you go and that's kind
of how the Reps remain where they remain
you know as the conduit and then
sometimes I'll have uh folks who will
uh yeah folks who will like be like oh
here's my card and then that kind of
lets you know
hey the meeting went well but also they
have a maybe different kind of
relationship they're trying to build